Hi, everybody. My name
is Christina Bugani
and I'm one of
the academic
medicine scholars
for this year.
Today we're going
to be talking about
dermatologic emergencies
and I want to give
a huge shout out to
doctor Magano for letting
me work on this
lecture with
her and for all her
help and guidance.
So the session objectives
for today are
going to include
recognizing the potentially
life threatening
dermatologic conditions
both visually and
through descriptions,
explain the
pathogenesis of
certain dermatologic
conditions,
describe drug induced
autoimmune or
infectious
etiologies of life
threatening dermatologic
conditions,
and manage the best
course of action for
stabilization and
treatment initiation
for dermatologic
emergencies.
This is our session
outline for today,
going through
everything we're
going to be talking
about in order.
So first, we'll talk
a little bit about the
basics of evaluation.
Most rashes that are
coming in through
the emergency room aren't
necessarily going to
be a true emergency,
but it's going to be
really important
to be able to
recognize when
those rashes
can be an emergency.
The thing you're
going to want to
monitor for always
is going to
be their airway breathing
or circulation, the ABCs.
You want to keep
an eye out for
those abnormal
vital signs.
You want to keep an eye on
their oxygen saturation
and any changes in
mental status as those
could potentially clue you
into impending
airway collapse.
Next, you want to be
sure to take a
thorough history.
This can clue you into
what is currently going
on with the patient.
Some important
things to ask are
any events leading up to
the patient's current
presentation,
any recent exposure to
new foods or medications,
any plant or
insect exposure.
You're going to want
to ask the patient if
they have any
known allergies,
ask them if they're
on any type of medication,
and you're also
going to want
to ask them for past
medical history.
And then the physical exam
is also very important.
You want to make sure you
are actually visualizing
the skin when you perform
a physical exam on
patients complaining
of a rash.
You want to look at
the appearance of
those lesions,
any distribution
as that can
help clue you into
the type of rash.
You're also going
to want to check
for any mucosal
involvement
and we'll talk a
little bit later
about why that
could be important.
Any systemic signs.
You want to check
to see for things
like if the patient
has a fever.
The first pathology we'll
talk about is urticaria,
which is commonly
defined as
an intensely pruitic well
demarcated pink
annular swelling
of the superficial
dermis and
has an erythematous
flare border.
It can be called a
wheel or a hive.
It doesn't always
progress to anaphylaxis,
but it can and
that's when it
can be considered
life threatening.
So like I
mentioned before,
you want to monitor
those vitals,
any mental status changes
that can clue you
into nearing
airway collapse.
Oftentimes, the
causes of urticaria
are going to be food
and medications.
You want to make sure you
take a thorough history.
Here we have a
picture of what
urticaria could look like.
You see those edematous
erythematous plaques
with a slightly
central pallor.
Next is angioedema.
Angioedema is swelling of
the deeper dermal and
subcutaneous tissues
of the mouth,
lips, tongue.
When we start to
get angioedema of
the lower airway that can
lead to airway compromise.
There are two subtypes.
The first is a
hereditary variant,
it's autosomal dominant
and it's due to
a C one esterase
inhibitor deficiency.
The second type
of angioedema
is acquired and it's due
to angiotensin
converting enzyme
or ACE inhibitors,
which are a very
common anti
hypertensive medication
and NSAIDs.
A little bit about the
pathophys and what's
going on here,
I've attached a picture
of the pathway.
Essentially, in angioedema,
what's happening
is that increased
bradykinin
is what's causing it.
So in the case of
C one sterse
inhibitor deficiency,
if you look at the left
side of this pathway,
C one esterase inhibitor
allows for regulated
bradykinin.
So when we have a
deficiency in that,
that will actually
lead to increased
bradyinin
and can potentially
lead to angioedema.
With ACE inhibitors, they
also ACE helps contribute
to the degradation
of bradykinin.
So ACE inhibitors stop
the degradation
of bradykinin.
Again, we have that
increased bradyokin
that could potentially
lead to an angioedema.
So the way to manage
entry angioedema is going
to be through
early intubation.
You don't want to
wait until the airway
fully collapses and then
it's very hard
to intubate.
You want to make
sure you're
proactive with
these patients.
You want to maintain
an 02 saturation
of greater than 90%,
so you want to be mindful
of monitoring that.
And after that, you're
going to want to
determine the cause.
If it's due to
a medication,
let's say the patients
taking an ACE inhibitor,
you want to make sure
to discontinue
that medication.
If they also have
urticaria present,
it's possible
that they had
a potential
allergic trigger,
so you can consider
administering
antihistamines,
glucorticoids,
and epinephrine.
If the patient has a
hereditary variant
that's causing
this angioedema,
there are certain
medications
that can be used.
A catban is
a bradykin
receptor inhibitor
that can be used.
Acenide is a
Kalcrine inhibitor,
which is also going
to help decrease
bradykinin.
You can also use
C one esterase
inhibitor and replenish
that and you're at
a hospital that doesn't
have these types
of resources,
fresh frozen plasma is
something that you
could also consider.
Before discharge
of the patient,
towards the end of
their hospital stay,
if the patient presented
with an anaphylaxis,
you're going to want to
make sure you prescribe
an auto injector
epinephrine and give
them education and
counseling on how
to use that auto injector.
If you've identified
a trigger,
you're going to want
again to counsel
and educate your
patient on how
to avoid those
allergens and
triggers to avoid
this situation.
Basically, these
patients are all
getting admitted
into the ICU.
Here we have some pictures
of what angioedema
could look like.
You get the
severe swelling
of the mouth region,
the mouth, the tongue,
and there's probably
also swelling in
that lower airway
causing airway collapse.
Next we have
erythema multiforma.
This is a type
of rash that
90% of the time is
caused by infections.
The most common of which
is herpes simplex virus.
That's the number one
infectious cause.
The second cause can be
mycoplasma pneumonia.
About 10% of
erythema multiforme
is going to be caused
by some kind of a drug.
Um, so this develops
usually secondary to
a herpes simplex
virus infection via
cell mediated immune
response directed
at viral antigens that
are deposited in
the lesion skin.
This is a clinical
diagnosis
like most rashes are,
but what you're
really going to see
are those
targetoid lesions
with a central
dusky appearance
is how they're
commonly described.
Erythema multiforma can be
divided into
minor or major.
So if it's erythema
multiforma minor,
it's usually without or
with very mild
mucosal disease.
And without any
associated symptoms
and resolves easily.
But if they have severe
mucosal involvement
and potential systemic
symptoms like a fever,
conjunctivitis, colitis,
that would be
considered erythea
multiforming major.
The symptoms could be
malaise, low grade fever,
and then those targoid
lesions are going
to develop over
several days and
they're going to be
painful and
pariic or itchy.
So the lesions and
erythema multiforma
are going
to appear over the course
of three to five days,
specifically in the
palms and soles.
They can spread outside
of that as well, though.
The lesions typically are
going to resolve within
14 days and they're
usually not going to scar,
but they can be
hyperpigmented
for a few months.
You can treat
erythema multiforme
with antivirals if you
find that the cause of
this was herpes
simplex virus.
You can also use
acyclovir to
prevent recurrence of
erythema multiforme.
If the cause of this
was drug induced,
then you're just going
to want to avoid
drugs in the future.
You'll consider systemic
steroids if it's severe
and a dermatology consult
as with most of
these rashes.
You'll also want
to provide your
patient with
supportive care.
So here we have
pictures of
the erythema
multiforma rash.
You can see those
characteristic
targoid lesions
with that dusky
appearance in the middle.
This is another
picture of what
that erythema
multiforma rash
could look like
more widespread.
Next, we're going
to talk about
Stephen Johnson
syndrome and
toxic epidermal
necrolysis or ten.
Stephen Johnson syndrome
and ten used to be
considered as part
of a spectrum
with erythema multiform,
but now new text
is trying to
separate the two.
Just be mindful of that
while you're reading.
Sometimes they could
consider them to be
together or
separate diseases.
So Stephen
Johnson syndrome
or ten is an
epidermal detachment.
This disease is severe,
it's very life threatening
and it can be very
traumatic for
the patients.
What's the difference
between the two?
Stephen Johnson
syndrome is going to
be less than 10% of
body surface area,
experiencing epidermal
detachment, whereas
toxic epidermal
necrolysis is
going to be greater
than 30% of
body surface area,
experiencing
epidermal detachment.
This is something
that you're going
to want to recognize in
your patients right away
if you want to
keep them alive.
The causes are typically
drug induced,
medication induced.
There is a list of
medications that are
known to cause Steven
Johnson syndrome.
When physicians
prescribe
these medications
to their patients,
this is something
that they'll counsel
on and you will just let
your patient know
that this is one
of the side effects
and what to look
out for so you can
get your patient into
the hospital as soon as
possible if they start
to see symptoms.
The patient can
have several doses
of any of these
medications
before they get
this reaction.
It's important to
counsel possible
side effects just
like any medication.
The most common
drugs that can cause
Stephen Johnson
syndrome is
going to be antibiotics,
specifically your
sulfa medications
and penicillins,
anticonvulsants
like lamotrigen,
phentin and carbamazpine,
barbiturates, NSAIDs,
allopurinol, which is
a common gout drug.
The pathogenesis
is predominantly
a drug specific CD eight
positive cytotoxic T
cell mediated reaction
that leads to
epidermal necrolysis.
There could be
potential for
genetic predisposition.
The diagnosis, again,
likely clinical,
you're going to have
a positive Niklski sign
in these patients.
What that is is
when you apply
gentle pressure
to the skin with
your thumb and gentle
perpendicular pressure,
the skin is going to
very easily slide off.
Um, Skin biopsy is
going to show
keratinocyte necrosis.
This is a picture
of Nkolski sign,
and it really nicely shows
that it looks
like someone just
applied gentle pressure
with their thumb slid
across the skin
and that skin
just sloughed right
off very easily.
The symptoms, about
one to three weeks
between the first
drug exposure
and symptom onset,
there's going to
be a prodrome,
so one to two
weeks of fever,
athralgia and
then after that,
patients will
typically get
a rash and that rash
is irregular shaped,
it's painful macules,
they're going
to quickly spread
and coalesce.
The epidermis
starts to slough
off and this can progress
over hours to days.
The important
thing to keep in
mind with Steven Johnson's
and ten is that they
have mucous membrane
involvement.
They will have pain
with swallowing
and you will see
that mucous membrane
involvement.
The patient is very
aware of how
painful this is.
They're going to
feel the burning,
they're going to be
tachycardic and
hypertensive.
So the prognosis for
this depends on
the percentage
of skin necrosis.
The mortality rate in
Stephen Johnson is
going to be 5%
and for ten,
it's going to be
greater than 20%.
These patients are
increased risk
of electrolyte imbalance,
multi organ failure,
infection, and
dehydration.
You're going to want to
treat these patients
like they're having
a severe burn.
If there's a burn
unit available
at the hospital,
you're going to want
to transfer them over,
or they'll have
care in the ICU.
You want to right away
discontinue the drug
that's causing this.
You also want to
make sure you educate
and counsel the patient
on the entire list
of medications
that could cause
Stephen Johnson
syndrome because
these patients
should avoid
those drugs at
all costs as
the second time that
this could happen,
it's going to get worse.
Of course,
supportive care,
making sure you're giving
them their fluid
replacement,
correcting any electron
abnormalities, Um,
giving something for
pain control,
if necessary,
you're going to want
to give antibiotics
to avoid any sepsis
as they're more
prone to infection
and maybe
consider a protection
ventilation
if you feel that
patient needs it.
In the long term, they
could have ocular effects,
pulmonary effects,
psychiatric long
term effects.
You're going to need a
multidisciplinary team
to help these patients
in the long term.
This could be pretty
traumatizing disease,
so that's why
you would bring
psycho on board as well.
And this is a
picture of the
Steven Johnson's or in
this case,
probably ten ash.
Next, we'll talk about
staphylococcal called
skin syndrome.
This is a disease
that primarily is
going to affect
children likely
due to breaking
of the skin
barrier leading
to a staph infection.
In infants, a common area
that this could be in
is the diaper region where
it's a lot easier to have
that irritated
broken skin,
and that can
be easy access
for staph infection.
The diagnosis,
again, clinical,
positive Niklski sign,
so that skin
will slough off.
Um, symptoms are going
to include fever,
irritability,
conjunctivitis, nra,
very tender skin that
becomes scalded
and blistered,
erythematous and has
these flaccid bullae,
and then the epidermis
will start to decicmate
over three to five days
and it's going to leave
behind this
tender raw skin
that's very
similar to a burn.
So what's important
to keep in mind
here is that the mucous
membranes are spared.
This is a good way
to differentiate
this sloughing of the skin
from Stephen
Johnson syndrome.
The management and
treatment for this is
going to be IV
antibiotics,
specifically the
ones targeting
staph infections,
napsllin,
oxiclin and
supportive care,
including the same as
the others, fluid,
electrolyte corrections,
the wound care,
rehydration and
pain control.
This is a picture of
what staphylococcus
called skin syndrome
could look like.
Next, we'll talk about
toxic shock syndrome.
What typically
causes this is
any kind of packing
that can be prone
to infection.
It's commonly associated
with tampon use,
but it could also be
post op packing
that's left,
abscesses, nasal packing,
So the pathogenesis
is going
to be either group
A strep exotoxins
or Sp aureus infection.
Essentially, you get
a super antigen
mediated T cell
activation that leads to
this massive
cytokine release
and capillary leakage,
hypotension, and
multi organ failure.
So the mortality
rate is about 6%,
but we can decrease that
with appropriate
treatment measures.
How you diagnose this
is the patient
is usually going
to have a group A strep
or staphoreus
infection present.
But sometimes it might
take a while to get
a confirmatory
blood culture.
They'll have fever of
greater than one oh two,
a significant
fever, presence of
hypotension, a
rash, desquamation,
and two of the following,
diarrhea, vomiting,
renal impairment,
elevated liver enzymes,
respiratory
distress syndrome,
just to name a few.
Again, the main
symptoms for
toxic shock syndrome are
going to be that
very high fever,
a decemative rash of
the palms and soles,
hypotension, and
multi system
organ involvement
for three or more systems.
1-2 weeks after
illness onset is when
that pruritic
maculopapular rash
occurs on the body.
And then one
to three weeks
after illness onset is
when presence
of declamation
of the palms and
soles occurs.
How to treat this,
you're going to want
to right away remove
any kind of packing,
which is going to be the
source of infection.
Let's say someone forgot
to remove their tampon,
you want to go in
right away and remove
that tampon as if
that's what's causing
the infection.
And the toxic
shock syndrome.
You're also going
to want to provide
supportive care for
these patients.
IV fluids, remember,
they're hypotensive,
so consider
vasopressors to bring
the blood pressure back up
and any IV antibiotics,
clindamycin and
vancomycin or nafcillin.
To prevent this
in the future,
you want to make
sure you can suit
your patients on
proper tampon use,
proper wound care,
things like that.
Here's a picture of
that maculopapular
rash that could occur.
This is a picture of
the decemative rash
that could occur of
the palms and soles.
Next, we'll talk about
Pemphgus vulgaris.
This is an autoimmune
condition in which
IgG antibodies
are targeted against
desmoglein three,
which is present
in the skin,
and that leads to a
blistering eruption.
Again, with this, you have
a positive Nkolski sign.
A skin biopsy is going
to show IGG deposits in
a reticular pattern along
the dermal
epidermal junction
on direct
immunofluorescence.
Symptoms are
going to include
flaccid by that
rupture and that leads
to painful areas
that are prone to
secondary infection
and there could
also be mucosal
involvement for this.
To treat, you're going
to want to admit
the patient,
provide plasmapheresis
and IVIG as
that helps to
take out some of
the antibodies that
could be causing this.
Any steroids and
immunosppressives,
you'll consider.
You want to treat
fluid and electrolyte
disturbances
aggressively and get a
dermatology consult.
This is what the pamhegs
bulgaris rash
could look like.
Next, we have drug
reaction with
eosinophilia and systemic
symptoms or dress.
This is something
that you see in
about two per 100,000
patients per year.
There is a clear drug
trigger and 80% of
dress cases and can
be associated
with HLA genes.
It's considered a delayed
type four
hypersensitivity reaction
that leads to severe
drug eruption,
organ involvement, and
peripheral eosinophilia.
The mortality rate
in patients with
stress is going to
be about two to 10%.
Um Symptoms are
going to include
a latency phase of
about 2-8 weeks
from when the patient
starts the drug to
when the actual
symptoms start.
Those symptoms
are going to
include an extensive
skin rash,
fever of greater than 101,
and visceral organ
involvement,
lymphadenopathy,
and eosinophilia.
Very rarely are you going
to see mucosal
involvement.
If it's there,
it's probably
mild and skin detachment
is rarely seen.
You don't have
that positive Niklski
sign in dress.
Liver injury
is going to be
the most common
visceral manifestation.
Sometimes patients
can get facial edema,
and how we manage or treat
this in patients that
have severe dress,
we're going to want to
admit to the hospital
right away, provide
organ support.
We're probably admitting
this patient into the ICU.
The thing you're going
to want to do is
identify what
the medication
was that caused this and
withdraw it right
away and avoid
introducing any
new kinds of
medications until the
patient's symptoms
have resolved.
You'll want to do
a long taper of
systemic corticosteroids,
give supportive
care to the patient
and because
there's so much
of visceral organ
involvement in dress,
They might potentially
need follow
up with multiple
specialists.
Depending on what organs
dress will target for
the specific patient,
you'll consider referrals
to all those specialists,
for example, hepatology,
nephrology, or
pulmonology.
Here we have a list
of all the drugs that
are implicated in dress.
Some of the common agents
are going to be
allopurinol,
those anticonvulsant
medications,
the sulfa drugs,
vancomycin, anti
tuberculosis drugs.
Those are all
common agents
that can lead to dress.
Here we have pictures
of a patient that
has dress and you
can see that facial edema
and the
characteristic rash.
Next, we could go
through a couple of
practice questions just to
check your knowledge on
what we've learned so far.
A 25-year-old
patient presents
to the emergency
department with fever and
a diffuse erythematous
rash ten days after
being diagnosed with a UTI
and beginning
appropriate treatment.
On physical exam, Nicholski
sign is positive.
About 5% of the skin is
involved including
mucous membranes.
Which of the following
is most likely diagnosis?
You guys can pause through
these questions and try to
figure out what the
right answer is.
The correct answer is
C Stephen Johnson
syndrome.
This patient
probably began
an antibiotic for
treatment of UTI and
has sloughing of
the skin with
a positive Nilski sign
and includes
mucus membranes.
That leads us to
either Stephen
Johnson syndrome
or toxic epidermal
necrolysis.
Here I gave you
that about 5%
of the skin is involved,
because it's
less than 10%,
we would go with
answer choice
C. If it was
greater than 30,
then the right
answer would be
E, toxic epidermal
necrolysis.
Next, we have a
20-year-old female patient
who presents to
the emergency
department with fever,
rash on her
hands, complaints
of fatigue for one week.
Her vials include
a temperature of
103 and a blood
pressure of 80/50.
On physical exam
of the skin,
a declamating rash is
present on the
palms and soles.
Which of the
following will most
likely also be a finding.
The answer choice here is
C history of tampon use.
This is a patient that
has a high fever,
is hypotensive and has
decremating
rash present in
the palms and soles.
She is a
20-year-old female,
so it's very likely given
the clinical picture that
she has toxic
shock syndrome,
and this is a common cause
of toxic shock syndrome is
any kind of packing
that's been left behind
and is causing
some infection.
History of tampon use
would fit the picture.
Next, we have a
55-year-old male patient
presenting to the
emergency department
with painful lesions
on his trunk.
On physical exam, positive
Nkolski sign is present.
A biopsy is performed
and reveals IDG along
the dermal
epidermal junction
on direct
immunofluorescence.
Which of the following
best describes
the underlying
pathogenesis
of this patient's
condition.
So for this patient,
they have IgG along
the dermal
epidermal junction.
That describes the
biopsy findings
for pemphgoid vulgaris.
The answer choice is A,
it's going to be due to
auto antibodies against
desmoglein leading to
the disruption of
keratinocyte adhesion.
Next, we're going
to talk about
meningiocoxmia.
This is most
commonly seen in
patients that are younger
than 20-years-old,
although it can
also be seen in
patients who have a
complement deficiency,
patients who don't
have a spleen,
and patients that are
commonly found in
areas of crowding.
For example, like
dorms or prisons.
But most patients are
presenting younger
than 5-years-old.
This disease has a
mortality of ten to 14%.
What's causing this is
a fatal systemic
infection due to
gram negative diplococcus
era meningitis
and it's transmitted
through aerosolized
droplets.
The way you're
going to diagnose
meningitis is going to
be through a
lumbar puncture.
And symptoms are going
to develop three
to four days after
the exposure and rapidly
progress to
severe illness.
The patient is
going to have
a headache, fever,
altered mental status,
they could have nausea,
vomiting, myalgia,
neck stiffness.
The dermatologic finding
here is going to
be a pul or purpuric rash.
How are you going
to treat this?
Firstly, you're
going to want to
contact public
health officials,
admit the patient
to ICU for
close monitoring and
provide supportive care.
Antibiotic treatment
is going to be indicated,
so you're going to
give your patient
IV third generation
cephalosporin
and IV vancomycin.
Again, you're going
to want to make
sure that you're
checking their vitals,
checking for signs of
shock in case they
need any kind of IV
fluid resuscitation.
How do we prevent this
with vaccination.
Here is a picture of
that rash that you
could see with
meningocemia.
So necrotizing fasciitis
is pretty rare,
about 0.4 per 100,000
people annually in the
US will present with this.
It is a very aggressive,
very rapidly progressing
skin and soft tissue
infection that is due to
a bacterial toxin
release and
causes that fascia
subcutaneous
tissue necrosis
and septic shock.
Causes of this, it can
occur anytime you're
breaking skin integrity.
So it could be
after surgery,
after any invasive
procedure,
or it could even be after
minor procedures
like phlebotomy.
Most commonly it's due to
gram positive coccci
like cephahoureus,
streptococci clastridium,
it can be due
to anaerobes.
Risk factors are going
to include diabetes,
immunosuppressed people,
any kind of trauma,
liver cirrhosis, and
history of alcoholism.
The mortality
rate for this
is going to be 20 to 80%.
It's very poor prognosis.
Diagnosis for this is
that you need to have
a very high index of
clinical suspicion
when you see that
this patient is in
intense pain because
this infection
can spread rapidly
within hours.
Signs and symptoms
to look out for is
excruciating pain out of
proportion to the
presenting symptoms.
Systemic septic signs,
tenderness to
palpation outside
of the erythematous
border,
cellulitis, and
a really big one
is going to be
subcutaneous
emphysema increpitis.
As that's from the gas
that's being released
from the bacteria.
Management and
treatment for this is
going to be as soon as
possible surgery
console because
this patient's going to
need immediate
debridement.
That's the best standard
of care for this.
You want to make
sure you keep
your patient NPO,
meaning nothing by mouth.
Ultimately, they're
going to be
transferred for
care in the ICU.
But the first
thing you want
to do is get them
into surgery.
These patients will
have aggressive
fluid resuscitation
measures and
pressures to counteract
any hypotension
if they're experiencing
septic shock.
And you're going to
want to early on,
provide empiric broad
spectrum antibacterial
coverage.
Here we have a CT scan
that shows that gas that
forms from the bacteria
in those subcutaneous
tissues.
It's going to be that
hypoacoic darker area
on the CT scan.
Here we have
some images of
what necrotizing fasciitis
could look like.
This is an image of the
surgical debridement.
Next is herpesoster virus.
This is due to
reactivation of
the latent varicel
exostervirus
in previously
exposed individuals.
Here you see a picture of
that characteristic
dermatomal rash
on one side that
presents with
herpeoster virus.
Risk factors for
herpeaster virus
are going to be
increased age,
any kind of
mechanical trauma,
psychological stress,
immunosuppression,
exposure to infected
individuals.
What's really important
to keep in mind with
herpe disaster
is that a lot
of time patients will
complain about pain.
And this is when it's
important for you to go
ahead and actually check
the skin of where
they're complaining
about pain.
For example, someone in
the emergency room
can come in and say,
I have this left
sided chest pain
and you're going to
go through a whole
cardiac workup.
Then when you actually
expose the skin,
you'll see that they have
this dermatomal
unilateral rash on
the left side and
you would much
easily diagnose with
a herpeoster virus.
Just keep in mind to
always expose the skin.
So herpesoster
opthalmicus is
a type of
herpesoster in which
the vari exostervirus
lies latent
specifically in the
trigeminal ganglion
and it reactivates.
When it does reactivate,
it specifically affects
the ophthalmic branch
of cranial nerve
five and that's
why you get
that vesicular rash in
a dermatomal distribution.
You get it over the
eye unilaterally.
Diagnosis is going to
be clinical recognition of
that vesicular rash
along the ophthalmic
dermatome.
There is something
called Hutchinson sign,
which is when those
fascicular lesions
specifically occur
on the nose,
and that's affecting the
nasal ciliary branch
of the ophthalmic branch
of cranial nerve five.
Why is this
here is because
it's an ophthalmic
emergency.
This can lead
to vision loss,
so you want to be able to
recognize it right away
and get an
ophthalmology console.
So symptoms are
going to include
a prodrome of
vague symptoms,
just pain is present
in the area, photophobia,
blurry vision, headache,
maybe some vision changes,
you're not going
to see a rash at
first until they go
into the active phase,
which is about
one to five days
after the prodrome.
Skin lesions are going to
develop and
they're commonly
described as
herpetiform cluster
of erythematous
of vesicles.
Vesicles is a huge
board's word.
They evolve through
stages of pustulation,
ulceration, and crusting,
and they're going
to be unilateral.
They do not cross midline.
Unilateral along the
ophthalmic dermatome.
Then patients can
progress into
a chronic phase in which
the pain persists
for months to years.
If the pain is
greater than 30 days
after the resolution
of cutaneous lesions,
it's going to be
considered post
herpaic neuralgia.
And how do we manage
and treat this?
You're going to want
to give your patient
early oral antivirals,
specifically acyclovir,
control any pain,
and right away get an
ophthalmology consult.
Like I said, this is an
ophthalmic emergency,
your patient could
lose their vision,
so you want to call
opt right away.
Typically, the
treatment is
going to be
corticosteroids,
but you're not
going to want to
administer that
as even just
administering
corticosteroids to the eye
can lead to significant
eye damage,
so you want to do
everything with
that optalcsult.
And this is an image
of Hutchinson's sign.
Again, that vesicular rash
is present on one side,
on the nose, that's
called Hutchinson's sign.
This is also going to
need an Otho console,
even though that rash is
not present over the eye,
it still can lead
to vision loss.
You want to make
sure you call
OPO right away.
Next, we'll talk about
Rocky Mountain
spotted fever.
This is a tick borne
illness called by
Racetzia Retzi and it's
usually transmitted from
the American dog tick.
And it's typically
endemic in
Southeast and South
Central United States.
If you don't give
antibiotics to
these patients,
the mortality rate
is 20 to 30%.
To diagnosis,
you're going to
want to have a high
index of suspicion
when there is a
patient presenting
with flu like
symptoms during
the summer that recently
traveled from Southeast or
South Central
United States,
whether or not they
have a known tick bite,
you're going to want to
have a high index of
suspicion because of the
high mortality rate.
Pathogenesis for this is
that the disease
is infecting
the vascular
endothelial cells
lining small and
medium vessels,
and that leads to
a disseminated
inflammation,
loss of barrier function,
and altered
vascular permeability
in the body.
This is what's causing
systemic symptoms.
Those symptoms are
going to begin
about 4-10 days
after the tick bite.
They'll have a triad
of fever, headache,
and peticial or
macular papillar rash
starting at the
wrists and ankles.
They could have
other symptoms
of altered mental status,
cardiovascular
instability,
lymphadenopathy,
and myalgia.
How do we treat this?
You're going to
want to treat with
doxycycline.
If you guys remember
from antibiotics,
doxycycline has a side
effect of causing
tooth discoloration
in children
and can be
contraindicated.
This is a situation
where that is
not the case.
Because of the very
high mortality rate,
we're actually even
going to treat
children with
doxycycline as
the benefits of
giving doxycycline in
this scenario
outweigh the risks.
To prevent that
high mortality,
we'll take the tooth
discoloration,
unfortunately.
Um, and while
you're getting
confirmatory lab
tests, again,
because of the
high mortality,
you're not going to want
to delay treatment.
You're just going to give
the doxycycline
right away while you
wait for those
lab tests if
you have a high
suspicion for this.
Next, we'll talk
about burns.
They're common
in household
and industrial accidents.
It can be seen in
cases of abuse,
electric currents,
fires, steam,
UV radiation, so you get
direct tissue
damage leading to
fluid loss and causing
infection risk.
The way to evaluate
your burns
is going to be figuring
out what the
type of burn is.
Most burns are going
to be thermal,
but they can also
be chemical,
electrical, radiation.
You're going to
want to figure
out the extent
of the burn.
You want to figure out
what percentage of
the total body surface
area is involved.
For that, you're
going to use what's
called the rule of nines.
I attached a picture here
how you can make a
quick calculation
to see what percent of
the body is affected.
Then you also
want to see the
depth of the burn.
There are different
criteria here.
It could be superficial,
superficial partial,
deep partial
full thickness
or deeper burn injury.
So here we have
an image showing
the different
depths of burn.
For superficial
burns that's
just affecting
the epidermis,
that's going to be very
similar to a sunburn.
Then you have superficial
partial thickness
in which the
burn goes into
the papillary dermis and
these burns are going to
be blistering and painful
to temperature and air.
You have the deep
partial thickness,
which burn,
which is in the
epidermis and reticular
dermis and you get
easily unroof blisters.
These are going to be
actually painless.
Patients at
this point have
experienced enough
damage where
they have perception
only to pressure.
An example of those
partial thickness burns
is going to be burns
from hot surfaces,
hot liquids or flames.
Then you have full
thickness burns.
Those are going to go
through all through
the epidermis and
the full thickness
of the dermis.
Here we're going
to start to see
a white waxy consistency.
Again, these will be
painless and maybe
these patients will
perceive deep pressure.
Full thickness burns
can occur from flames,
hot liquids or
superheated gases.
Then we have deeper
burn injuries,
and this is when the
burn goes as far
as through the layers
of the fascia and muscle.
Again, these will
also be painless and
maybe patients will have
some perception
of deep pressure.
How do we treat burns?
Minor burns can be
cooled, cleaned, covered,
and you can provide
comfort to your
patients with over
the counter pain
medications
or prescription pain
medicines if needed.
If the burns are
classified as severe,
meaning that they
are greater than 10%
of the total body
surface area,
you're going to want
to consider referral
to a burn center.
You'll also want IV
fluid resuscitations
to maintain patients
urine output.
Also for these patients,
you'll provide pain
control, wound care,
any kind of topical
antibiotics,
and if it's very
severe, you'll
consider skin
grafting as well.
Here we have the
guidelines from
the American Burn
Association on
when you should
refer a patient
to a burn unit.
Patients who have
thermal burns,
if they're full thickness
burns should be
transferred.
Any kind of
partial thickness
greater than 10% total
body surface area,
If it's affecting
any part of the
face, hands,
genitalia, feet,
perineum, you're
going to want to
transfer if they also
have poorly
controlled pain.
For inhalation injuries,
those are all going
to be transferred.
Any chemical injuries will
also be transferred and
any electrical injuries of
high voltage or
lightning injuries.
Pediatric burns,
for the most part
are also going to be
referred to a burn center.
All right. We have a
couple more questions.
A 20-year-old female is
brought to the
emergency room by
her college roommate
who describes
that she has been
acting very confused.
Her vitals include
a fever of 102.
Physical exam findings
include nuchal rigidity,
a positive cronic sign,
and a diffuse pteial rash.
Which of the following is
the best initial
treatment?
So this patient is
a college roommate,
has altered mental status,
positive Kernig sign,
has that
characteristic rash,
so we're thinking
of meningoemia.
First line treatment
for this is going to
be ceftriaxone
and vancomycin.
A 50-year-old female
patient presents
to the emergency room
in excruciating pain.
She says she recently
returned from out of
country where she had
aesthetic surgery done.
Her past medical
history includes type
two diabetes mellitus
and hypertension.
On physical exam,
there's tenderness to
palpation of the
left buttock
and subcutaneous crepitus.
What is the most
appropriate next treatment?
This patient has
excruciating
pain, just as surgery,
so it was post op, has
a few risk factors
and has subcutaneous
crepitus.
We're likely thinking
this patient
has a necrotizing
fasciitis.
What you're going to
want to do as soon as
possible is get that
surgery console,
get the patient
into surgery
for surgical debridement.
Answer choice C is
the correct answer.
Next, we have
Kawasaki disease.
This mostly happens
in children
less than
10-years-old and it's
commonly seen in the
Asian population.
Pathogenesis is going to
include inflammatory
cells that are invading
the arteries
and that causes
disruption of
the internal elastic
lamina of the artery.
This is an immune
mediated pathogenesis.
Clinical diagnosis
and mnemonic
I like to use is
crash and burn.
For crash, you're going to
want four out of
the five letters.
Conjunctivitis,
rash of the palms and
soles, adenopathy,
specifically cervical
lymphadenopathy,
strawberry
appearing tongue
and oral mucosa
with dry cracked lips,
and hand and feet edema.
Four out of those
five and then burn.
Burn meaning fever of
greater than five days.
Those are the criteria
for Kawasaki disease.
This disease has
a high risk of
cardiovascular effects
including aneurysms
and thrombosis if you
leave it untreated.
The treatment for
this is going to be
aspirin to prevent
coronary artery aneurysms.
A way I like to
remember it is,
well, as you learned,
aspirin is
something that you
want to avoid in
children as it can
cause eye disease,
which is a hepatic
encephalopathy.
But Kawasaki disease is
going to be the exception.
I like to remember, avoid
aspirin in kids except in
Kawasaki disease and you
have ASA within Kawasaki.
You can remember,
this is the one
time you're going to
actually give it.
Again, because the
benefits of giving aspirin
are going to
outweigh the risk
of disease development.
There's a high incidence
of children developing
cardiovascular effects,
you're going to
want to make sure
you give the aspirin.
You'll also
want to provide
supportive care for
these patients.
You can give
them IVIG within
ten days of symptoms to
reduce side effects.
And reduce the risk of
coronary artery aneurysms.
You can also consider
giving corticosteroids.
After diagnosis,
you're going to want
to make sure you
obtain echocams to monitor
for
those cardiovascular
issues that could occur.
Here we have pictures
of the conjunctivitis,
the strawberry
tongue appearance,
the rash that could occur.
A couple of images of
the symptoms of
Kawasaki disease.
So the last disease we're
going to talk about is
going to be measles,
also known as
rubola disease.
This is something you
guys might want to pay
attention to because
unfortunately,
there has been an
outbreak in Texas
and now it has spread
to New York State.
Epidemiology,
it's going to
be more common in
patients who are
unvaccinated
for measles and
the cause is going to be
an acute infection
caused by
a single stranded
RNA paramexoviirs
transmitted through
respiratory droplets.
It's very contagious and
peaks in the winter
and springtime.
Um, Basically,
um, the virus is
entering the
respiratory tract.
It incubates for
ten days and
has a prodromal
phase of three days,
followed by a rash.
The symptoms and
measles are going to
be the fever and four Cs.
That's how I like
to remember it.
The four Cs are going
to stand for
conjunctivitis,
chorisa cough,
and Coplex box,
which isn't really a C,
but it's close enough.
Charis is actually going
to be a runny nose.
Um, and Coplex spots,
I have a picture
of it coming up,
but it's these blue
dots within the mouth,
within the mucosa on
top of a red base.
Fever and forces, cough,
conjunctivitis,
parasa Coplex spots.
Three days after the
onset of symptoms,
the patients will have
a maculopapular
erythematous rash
that starts on the face
and spreads to the
trunk and extremities.
Some complications
are going
to include encephalitis,
blindness,
and subacute sclerosing
panencephalitis,
which is a CNS
degenerative disease
that can happen
much later in life.
How you're going to
treat this and manage.
You're going to want to
contact public
health officials,
give supportive care
if it's uncomplicated.
You can give
patients vitamin A.
This is going
to help prevent
any corneal
ulcerations and
blindness and it's
going to help
reduce morbidity
and mortality.
But the best way
to prevent this is
going to be with
the MMR vaccine.
Here we have a
picture of what
the measles rash could
look like on different
shades of skin.
Here I've attached
a picture of
what those Coplex
spots could look like.
Just a few more questions
or one more question.
A 4-year-old
male presents to
the emergency room with
seven days of fever,
hand and foot swelling.
On physical
exam, they have
bilateral conjunctivitis,
erythematous mouth,
and rash of the palms
and soles present.
After proper care is
administered in the
emergency department,
which of the following
would be the
best next step?
The answer is
going to be B,
based on the presentation
of this patient,
they have Kawasaki
disease most likely.
You're going to want
to admit the patient
and perform
echocardiogram to
monitor for any kind of
coronary artery
aneurysms or thrombosis.
I've made two
summary slides
for you guys that you
can look through.
It's the most high
yield stuff from
this lecture that
could show up on
the exam just as a
quick review for
you to review
before your test.
I also have made an
optional activity that's
linked for you guys,
probably on Canvas.
It's basically
just pictures of
all the rashes since
that's something
that people can
struggle with
identifying the actual
image of the rash.
It's just a bank
of all the diseases
that we talked about.
Pictures of the diseases,
and you can try and
quiz yourself and
see if you can
identify each type of
rash and the answers
are going to be at
the end of the page.
Again, that activity
is totally optional if
it helps and references.
Thank you guys so
much for listening.
I hope you guys
like this lecture
and if you have
any questions,
you can feel free to
reach out to doctor
Magano at her email.
Thanks, guys.